both of these teams are running on point
streaks Dallas 30 and one in their last
four as the Canucks charge in bler with an
early tester and a save made Wedgewood bler
goes kening and then out in front pull it to
the backhand Dakota Joshua could not find it
early chances for Vancouver essentially
their third line and it can be a balance
Tipper for them they for check hard can play
physical what a golden opportunity for Bluer
immediately now le feed goes off of hoglander
the Stars will look to twist it the other way
Robertson The Dump was going wide snared
by the hand of Demco zorov came over in
the trade late November here's Johnston he
shot Sav Demco rebounds loose and gathered
by the Canucks they want to go the other way
it's Garland he's got Joshua Garland to Joshua
scores Dakota Joshua on the two onone and it's
the Canucks who grabbed the lead Less Than 3
minutes in scoring immediately just a Calamity at
the net front in the Canuck Zone and out of that
the Johnston line gets chasing back to their own
net again start CAU on a two-on one Garland looks
like he's going to shoot the puck you could see
mirro hkin in shade toward him Canucks Retreat
Pew Suter with an entrance stars were mixing in
the change MF steps wide left leaves it and the
save made by Wedgewood stolen by D jappi hinan
back for duchaine he'll step to the high slot
feed it to the right one timer and demp go the
save and Meyers just flings it to the corner but
right back to Dallas duch Shane little give and
go arren for hinet a few steps in L shot and a
save by De go just picked up where they left
off the entirety of this year Thomas Harley
up and down the near s side Johnston got one
through from the point now toov is first to it
Banks it it's a lean in shift from the fourth
line they had trouble getting it interior and
testing Deo there's Miller to the forehand and
net drive and Wedgewood made the save that's
two of those those are almost identical pluger
early and that one from Miller at Miller third
in NHL points 45 on the year here's hints Will
Bank it the reach by Ryan suder cross to hinan
back to the right and it blew up as hin mostly fan
then a wraparound chance save Demco hin couldn't
get it just outside the crease it's a sleeper
pick yes who would have had him four on four
continues as the Stars bring forward Duane
has San flip there score a onehanded poke
man are they something else Sean and Duan do
it again well they're they're just Gallant they
Skylar once they they get a hold of the puck and
they get control and from neutral ice they just
start picking them up and putting them down they
beat the Canucks to their net just flat out Sean
skated right past Ian Cole and a onand flash
stab to send it Against the Grain little top
of the circle down sauce here's aonic slides it
for Hughes from the blue line and to the right
Circle Pon clutches and rifles one off of the post
near side and Patterson's a Dandy on the flank and
he had Wedgewood just waving at this one shot it
past the on the near side there is suder cancels
with lafer p bski bounced one past hin right back
to hin he scores he was walking to the low slot
slid one past Deco and rope HS has Dallas with
their first lead of the night two to one score
some goals against Demco this is just four check
pressure they get after it go get it and beat the
Canucks to the front of the net hence down in the
corner can't Corral it Robertson knows where he's
going to go man those are quick hands right in
front aonic for Hughes KCK sitting on eight shots
this deep into the game Miller on the right wing
he'll turn look for help has it besser he scores
and Brock besser his 24th goal of the Season ties
the game at Brock besser's name in the game yet
tonight he peels off the bench and they go what
is known as downhill at the stars push him down
deep Miller did that little button hook curl and
he lays it right into the Wheelhouse of their top
scor one of the best goal scorers in the League
this year even though it just grazes the shoulder
of Wedgewood I think it clacked off of his own
Defender all of them have come on the road he's
had some looks here for his first home point that
would just send this place into a fry Garland to
the left wing back across Joshua back door set up
Garland scores the third line for Vancouver they
get their first lead since early in this game
garland from Joshua and it's 3-2 on the rush
and and the Stars unable to handle essentially
a three on four and somehow Garland was able to
give it up and then go home free to the back
door boy that was almost a blueprint and Deja
Vu of the overtime winner the star scored here
the other night Garland at the back post ready
for the puck drop hint on the stick side of Demco
and it's controlled by Vancouver Cole around but
not out Robertson feeding Thomas Harley his shot
he [Applause] scores the overtime hero earlier in
the week get a game time goal late in regulation
he is him mat what a great pinch by Miro hkin and
to keep a puck in that is such a difficult play
for a left-handed shot over on the right boards he
made it look easy and dainty Robertson finds the
hole Harley shows the patience of a Tibetan sand
artist to wait maybe fouled up dco a little bit
by getting clacked on to I think it clicked off
[Applause] of hinin in for dun poked away and that
with two on0 for Vancouver Pon with Joshua Pon to
Joshua Pon shot save well they needed the heroic
intervention after Miro hin and and Company turn
it over it's a two onone from three zones away 20
seconds Remain the Stars can't carve in cleanly
and they will get back to their own Zone one
last Rush Harley ahead sprung to Shane he's in he
scores
du Shane's the hero in the final seconds
of overtime and Thomas Harley with the
Liberation pass to duchaine he goes five hole
like a wet bar of soap his sixth game-winning
goal of the Season that leads the NHL
it's another electric overtime for 15
5 and 95 wowza nectarous and mortiferous
in combination he is quite the addition
his 11th goal of the year and two of
those gamewinners have come in overtime